what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into what's
probably or at least what I would
consider to be one of the greatest x-men
stories ever told this is God loves man
kills we're doing part one this is
actually a graphic novel 84 pages split
into four parts this story was written
back in 1983 and this is Chris Claremont
at his best but there is going to be a
moment in this video this might be a
little controversial but that was the
nature of Chris well there were a couple
moments really like when the story opens
up its controversial but but Chris
Claremont saw the x-men as like a soap
opera as opposed to like a traditional
superhero team and so he wrote them that
way and so the story that the story
reflects that so it's this is this is
classic Chris Claremont right so the
guys who were curious what Chris
Claremont x-men was like back during the
17 years he was writing it this is
exactly what it was like this I think is
like the penultimate x-men story like
the greatest expense story ever but what
this does is this opens up with a couple
of kids all right like a couple of young
kids and as they're running through
these kids Morgan Jill they're basically
fleeing for their lives and it's pretty
crazy because we're not initially given
an indication all we really get is this
thing where Jill asked about where their
parents are and Mark's response is well
don't worry about them they can't help
us anymore
and in the middle of them running Mark
is suddenly shot from behind and that's
when you basically realize who's chasing
after them that it's a group called the
purifiers now the purifiers I mean we're
gonna kind of suspend they're our
knowledge of like what the story is so
if you guys are familiar with this and
how it ends all I kind of do not spoil
anything please with a love of God do
not spoil anything but the purifiers are
pretty extreme which is exactly what
happens here and there's a reason why
Claremont does this but see one of these
purifiers is you know like like we're
purifiers and if you don't know what our
mission is you should know by now and so
we end up finding out the purifiers are
the ones that killed their parents and
then like chase that like these kids
just flee you know just just took off
for their lives as soon as the other
parents that died like what everything
happened and that's the nature of
Claremont riding right like Claremont
wouldn't always go through and give us
like a beginning a middle and an end to
a story he would just pick up in the
middle of it and then just go forward
towards the end and it was cool because
what it did is it kind of left your
imagination to wonder what happened
beforehand that led up to that and so we
don't see the parents of these kids
killed because the parents being killed
is not what's significant what's
significant is the Heartless nature of
the purifiers when they say like we're
gonna send you to meet your parents the
response of mark is you killed them and
they're like yeah and we're gonna kill
you too and they shoot him on the spot
they kill him on the spot
and then the little girl like Jill
starts crying she's like why why are you
doing this and then she's executed and
the response of the purifiers is because
you have no right to live
this is callous I mean it's the most
heinous reason like the most heinous
thing that a person could do not only
that just to add icing on the cake not
only that this takes place in a
playground so the purifiers take the
bodies of the kids string them up and
leave them for the world to see for like
every young person to see and it's and
it's it's so dark and it's so twisted
and so screwed up but that was the
nature of Chris Claremont's x-men Chris
Claremont x-men was designed to tell the
story of a persecuted group and that was
a reason why the x-men were so impactful
that Ken because it wasn't like the
x-men were just stand-ins for
african-americans they were stand-ins
for like 80 group that had ever been
persecuted that felt they'd been
persecuted and were legitimately
persecuted that's really what this was
about and so instead of you know young
people finding these kids bodies strung
up instead after the purifiers make
their escape magneto arrives and
Magneto's there and and you know
witnesses what had gone on or at least
is aware these kids had been executed he
wasn't purview to like the entire
goings-on of the purifiers and what they
had done but for Megan you know this is
crushing this is absolutely devastating
now this is also kind of a big deal and
the reason why is because when it
claimed when it when it came to
Claremont if he wasn't picking up
stories in the middle of everything he
was setting the groundwork for what
would come later and so it was not
uncommon to see Chris Claremont start a
theme and then finish it like five years
later because he had like all this time
that's where the reasons why when
Claremont just abruptly left in like
1992 it was it was such a huge blow to
Marvel because he had like all these
plot threads that have been going on it
all had to be wrapped up in a matter in
a matter of like six months to a year
but with this theme here this takes
place about three years before uncanny
x-men number 204 those are guys who
don't know what that means
that's the point where magneto takes
over leadership of the x-men and then
starts leading the New Mutants and so
that was basically you know Chris
Claremont's way of revitalizing his
character and turning him into a good
guy but for magneto this is devastating
to him because he has all this power I
like the power over magnetism like over
the electromagnetic spectrum he has all
this power he can shift the Earth's
poles he can issue an EMP like like a
minute EMP that'll take down power to
the planet there's all these things that
he could do but despite all that power
there's nothing he could do to say these
kids there's nothing he could have done
to save their lives and so that's why
it's so crushing is because he's like
always one step behind them and so from
here we switch over to the Stryker bill
Streicher worldwide as its referred to
which is the head of William Stryker
himself in this trucker crusade now this
is when his characters first introduced
and for those guys who don't know
William Stryker is a religious
fundamentalist he's he's extreme here's
the best way to a really good way to
picture William Stryker imagine the plot
to Handmaid's Tale
but it's mutants instead of women
essentially but nonetheless he's very
religiously motivated and the Stryker
crusade is literally a Christe a crusade
against mutant cons but to up to this
point it's largely been potshots it's
been shots unlike a mutant here a mutant
there what strikers looking for our big
fish and he's looking for the x-men and
that's why he has bats his uh basically
a secretary grabbing like all these
little these little recording tapes
these devices that show what the x-men
are capable of they kind of highlight
their powers and what they're able to do
and then brings them all in for William
Stryker to analyze because what he's
doing is essentially sitting down and
trying to plot a way to take out the
x-men and so it's it's it's interesting
here because one of the things that that
he really talked about at least one of
them just kind of hit on is that in his
mind Charles Xavier is the go-to guy
Charles Xavier is the guy that needs to
be taken out he's a leader of the x-men
to take him down would be a massive blow
against the x-men roster itself again
it's like mutant kind as a whole because
he's such a public figure now of course
this also coincides with him going to a
debate with Charles Xavier you know at
the ABC studio so it's actually kind of
a cool little thing here but at this
point we switch over to and encounter a
really kind of a bar fight basically
between Kitty Pryde and a kid named
Danny not hit he probably facing off
against Danny this was basically one of
those things that you didn't see all the
time but it was kind of a coming-of-age
scenario and the reason why I say that
is because when Kitty Pryde was
introduced to Marvel Comics and she was
made part of the x-men by Chris
Claremont she was very very very young
she was someone like 13 or 15 years old
or some along those lines but she was a
young girl who was coming into her own
who was basically understanding what it
meant to like grow up and become a woman
and different things like that and
that's why the character of storm was
brought in as a kind of surrogate mother
for Kitty Pryde so she could basically
raise or teach her how to walk how to
talk how to conduct herself in a womanly
way and also walk her through a lot of
the experiences that women go through as
their bodies are beginning to grow as
they're going through the whole you know
experience of growing up and heartbreak
and their bodies are changing and so on
and so forth and so with all that
happening there's also another character
here named Stevie Hunter now with this
whole fight that breaks out it's kind of
interesting because it's obvious Danny
had basically been been running off at
the mouth and we don't initially know
what had happened so you kind of have a
handful of people who were here in this
location at the same time right
Stevi hunter you have Colossus and
they're watching the events unfold now
in this instance you basically have
Colossus who kind of breaks up the fight
and you've got Stevie Hunter who comes
out and says what in the heck is going
on here and that's what we end up
finding out that Danny and his family
are part of the Stryker who said and
this was actually a brilliant maneuver
by William Stryker if what he's looking
to do is launch a crusade against mutant
kind you do not do it yourself you get
everybody else in society to do it for
you if American people are good at
anything
it's shunting blame to someone else and
say well it's not my fault the news made
me do it or like Jodie Foster told me to
do it or something like that but
American people really good at like
blaming others and this is kind of
absolving themselves a responsibility to
say well you know I'm only human I make
mistakes and so that's one of the
reasons why it's such a genius move
because it's the nature of people to do
that get people get the average American
to criminalize mutants to demonize
mutants and then you've got a walking
talking army of some 200 million people
who are your army that are gonna work on
your behalf to take down a million
mutants who exist in the United States
it's a genius maneuver but this is also
one of the more controversial moments
because in the midst of all this Stevi
basically tells Kitty Pryde you have to
let it go the guy's just saying things
because he's an [ __ ] like you have to
let it just kind of roll off you and the
responsive Kitty Pryde is would you take
the same the same stance if she called
you an N bomb lover I'm not gonna say it
but if she if she called you that would
you would you do that when this happened
when this was probably I was 2 years old
at the time I wasn't reading comics when
this when this when it's gone I'm sorry
I was even born when this came out but
like looking back at like the history of
comics when this happened when this was
put into a comic book it was huge it was
massive I mean it was it was like you
didn't do that you didn't do this I mean
in the history in the history of
publishing comics well african-americans
may been depicted certain ways while
like the step-in Fetchit mentality about
how people view african-americans was a
part of how african-americans were drawn
in comics you didn't drop the n-bomb in
a comic book that's just not something
that you did and when Chris Claremont
did this it was a gamble it was a very
very very dangerous game but it's not
designed for the purpose of just
throwing it out there and just saying
yep and bomb it's not designed to say
that instead what it's designed to do is
show the reality of the situation that
the x-men live in a persecuted group is
a very significant moment in this story
I'm not alone I can really emphasize how
important it is but it's one of those
things because when when Kitty Pryde
runs off the Responsive Colossus is look
Stevie you can't take it too personal
she's upset here you know she didn't
mean what she said and the responses TV
is actually she did she
really did like she really meant that
because it's true you know it's an
absence it is a definitive statement
which Stevie had felt the same way if a
different phrase had been thrown out
instead of mutti lover it was the n-bomb
law and so it's it's a it's a very
interesting thing because it was kind of
chris claremont skra teague of people
that like well so long as they're not
insulting my group that i don't really
care what it is they say you know it's
it's a it's a striking statement to make
but of course while this is all going on
it's all being observed by by purifiers
now the initial respond of the pure
response the purifiers is they're pretty
extreme because one of them is just like
well i mean she's a mutti lover killer
like i mean we we should just get rid of
her anybody who is a mutant or anybody
who sympathizes with them needs to be
taken out you know they're they're evil
they're bad we have to get rid of them
and so that's when you start going into
the debate that takes place between
Charles Xavier and and William Stryker
and the debate is cut short relatively
fast in a sense that as they're going
through and debating it's clearly
one-sided and there's a lot of things
that hit in on this for example when
William Stryker is talking to Charles
Xavier he quotes a statement that came
from Senator Robert Kelley's a committee
on mutant affairs now those you guys who
don't know what that is this takes place
during the events of project wide-awake
when the city president at the time was
running for re-election Senator Robert
Kelley was staunchly anti-mutant and
basically pushed the hand of the
president by running on the campaign of
saying well I'm against mutants and so
like mutants were credible and they're a
dangerous threat Senator Robert Kelly
used that and ran on that campaign
platform which meant the President had
to do it as well and so the president in
turn launched project wide awake the NSA
the FBI the CIA various state and local
police departments Sheriff's Department
so on and so forth all basically finding
a way to categorize quantify and to
control the mutant threat that's what
the whole thing was this Committee on
mutant Affairs was part of Senator
Robert Kelley's campaign and so that was
the whole idea was to find a way to
control mutants and when this report
came out this report was mutants are
legitimately dangerous they are people
with extraordinary powers some of whom
cannot control the powers they have and
because they can't control them they are
in of themselves a credible threat for
those who can control them how do we
keep them from killing all of us
that makes them a credible threat and
for the ones who seek to use their
powers for good there's simply not
enough of them to keep the ones who will
use them for evil in check so we can't
trust them to police themselves and so
again it was it was kind of building
this wall kind of building it building
you know building this wall that set the
X min intercept meetings in brick by
brick by brick to kind of isolate them
and to keep them segregated to say
they're inherently bad guys and so it's
kind of crazy here the
you have like people behind the scenes
you know like the guys in the in like
the rooms we're watching everything
unfold the people who are working at the
new station and their stance is yeah but
with all this stuff that Williams
trackers saying is absolutely terrifying
here but William with William Stryker
saying things like well means are a
credible threat means are dangerous
you're mutants are people who need to be
eliminated because you know they are
dangerous to the rest of American
society it's very much McCarthyism is
very much World War 2 era Germany this
is a group of people who are bad and I
have deemed them to be bad and we say
they're bad for arbitrary standards
therefore we must contain and control
them if not just outright eliminate them
it's calling for the deaths of millions
of people and it's a terrifying scenario
because where people look at that where
you have like members of the news who
are looking at this you have the x-men
looking at this and even when the whole
debate is done and Charles Xavier wasn't
able to make all those points when he
talks to Cyclops and says I think that
went poorly Cyclops response is
absolutely because you played to
people's reason you play to people's
logic but William Stryker played to
their fears and if anything fear is one
of the most powerful emotions ever when
people are afraid they will do whatever
they need to do they'll believe whatever
they want to believe in order to make
that fear go away and so if William
Stryker sitting on television and he's
saying well mutants are scary man now a
mutant could be your child or your child
or maybe your child goes to school with
a mutant and then they do something and
just wipe out all the kids in the
classroom it's fear-mongering and
because people are so easily terrified
they buy into it
and where you wear trousers later tries
to talk reason to it it doesn't work it
does not work because Charles Xavier it
looks imposing Charles Xavier
looks scary and because that William
Stryker played on that and ultimately
won the perceptions of people and so in
response to this the x-men are kind of
like okay look we don't want to have
anything to do with this right now we're
all gonna go work out and so for the
next little while the h-1 are just
working out in the Danger Room literally
just going through and and it's really
kind of chris claremont showcasing their
powers and what they can do and what
they're straightening the strengths and
weaknesses are and so on and so forth
and that while all that's going on the
purifiers launch their campaign they
launch their ambush on Charles Xavier
and storm and Cyclops and this is one of
the important things to bear in mind
when it comes to the purifiers they're
well organized through not just like a
bunch of crazy guys like them not a
bunch of like crazy Hicks or like hobos
or you know nonsensical people with
ridiculous beliefs who are just running
around with guns like herder or mutants
Byard like that that's not that's not
what they are but they're they're very
structured they're very organized but
more so than that the purifiers are
anybody the purifiers are white thank
you
businessmen and businesswomen
politicians you're designed to be a
stand-in for the Klan they could be
anyone in your town you could walk by a
purifier and never know that's what
makes them so dangerous because they're
so well organized so well hidden and
when they launch their attack against
Professor Xavier and Cyclops and storm
it is with dangerous precision they
shoot as they need to they take them out
as they need to it's fast and Swift I
mean it happens in a blink of an eye and
so from there you end up having you know
the x-men who are kind of you know
recouping from their workout and so on
and so forth and you know the phone
rings Nightcrawler picks it up and
Nightcrawler basically gets to call in
saying that Professor Xavier and Cyclops
and storm have all been killed okay so
continuing on with God loves man kills
again this is this is one of my favorite
stories guys I mean I love God loves man
kills and a lot of guys really seem to
enjoy to this old style of writing very
very soap opera like character focus you
know he writes action but it was focused
more on the nature of the characters
themselves now here's the thing in the
aftermath of the the death of Xavier or
at least of the perceived death of
Xavier Cyclops and storm um this sends
the x-men in a lot of ways into disarray
now it's one of the important themes
also bear in mind too when it came to
how the x-men were done by Claremont one
of the things that he established very
very early on is that they were very
much autonomous they did not rely
explicitly on Xavier to get their orders
and in fact this is kind of what the
x-men had been training for we Claremont
wrote these stories the idea was there
will come a time eventually when Xavier
is killed or Xavier is removed from the
landscape and the x-men have to be able
to know how to function accordingly now
the other half of this is Kitty Pryde
now Kitty Pryde as a character we talked
about her a little bit you know in the
the previous videos but I want to focus
a little bit more on her in this one
Kitty Pryde when she was brought into
the x-men
she was really designed to be like the
young readers kind of entry way into the
x-men mythos and what I mean by that is
Clement was very very good at writing
characters in such a way to where they
were relatable and so when you looked at
Wolverine he was obviously a character
who had been written in such a way that
he'd been around for a long time like
for quite some time and he'd seen and
done a lot of things and so with that
having been the case and it kind of
turned into okay so like he's the guy we
can follow to kind of get like the
backstory of what's going on with
regards to like what's been happening
around the planet his backstory was
ambiguous his health but with regards to
to what was going on behind the scenes
that was kind of a way to feed into that
you
looked at cyclops and it was like okay
what if we were like the leader of the
team Xavier was the teacher Jean Grae
was well she was the cheerleader more or
less under understand Lee and Jack Kirby
and then she became the one who was sort
of coming into her own under clamour
kind of you know rising in and becoming
something a little more prominent sort
of shooting up in the ranks but Kitty
Pryde was the one who was like if you're
brand new to x-men then like Kitty Pryde
is a character you follow because she
was brand new to the x-men she was just
some young wide-eyed kid who was brought
onto the team and she was learning what
it meant to be an x-man
as she fought alongside the x-men and so
she was learning about her powers but
she was also learning what it meant to
become a woman when she was being taught
these various things from storm and and
Stevie Ray and so on and so forth her
care to receive a lot of emphasis in the
fact that she was experiencing a lot of
tough times at a very young age she was
going through like all the puberty
stages that young kids go through at the
same time she was falling in love she
was she had a huge thing for Colossus
and she was kind of learning her place
in the bigger picture and so the idea of
a professor Eck's and Cyclops and storm
being killed is really kind of like a
huge thing for her because really like
the mentor she's been alerted that she's
been learning from are really like
perishing around her and so it's kind of
a big thing because it's like yes this
is the price we pay for being an x-man
but it's not something that you're
really prepared for even when it happens
now as she's going through I kind of
musing to herself where she's talking to
like Illyana Rasputin this the younger
sister of Colossus she really just kind
of goes off on her own does it run
thinking and then comes across was
essentially like a spy camera belonging
to the purifiers and again the purifiers
are spying on the x-men and have been
for quite some time and so at this point
we shift over to Wolverine and we shift
over to Colossus now this is one of the
big things about how Wolverine was
written back in it's something that you
don't really see anymore with his
character Wolverine was written as a
character where it were again you know
Chris Klem I sat down and said this
guy's been around for a long time when
Wolverine was part of Team X when he was
part of that black ops wet work team
working for the CIA I mean they they
took out political officials they took
out political rivals they took they they
toppled governments they did all kinds
of things and so Wolverine became very
very very very good at staging crime
scenes and so when he goes over here
with Colossus and he starts sniffing
around and he starts looking at what's
going on right off the bat he says this
is not what it looks like they weren't
killed they were taken from here and one
of the big questions is this ass is how
do you know this is like one I staged
enough crime scenes in my life to know
what a fake crime scene looks at but not
only that the bodies they found here are
not the bodies of of storm in Cyclops
inand
because they don't smell the sink the
nose nose the sent us off at the same
time you've got Wolverine kind of
looking around the area kind of putting
his his blackops experience to use
really like his longevity to use you've
got Nightcrawler who's analyzing
everything and they come up on the idea
there are guys who were sitting in this
car over there and they're basically
watching this they're watching the crime
scene they're looking to see what
happens and so those guys have to be in
on it and that's when we'll reign kind
of picks up on the idea they're involved
in this somehow and so you end up having
Nightcrawler who shows up you have
Wolverine who dons a costume we've got
Colossus who arrives and they try to run
him over and one of the one of the girls
is basically taking you know one of the
folks is taken out the car explodes in a
fiery crash and like two of the guys are
rescued now this is one of the things
that Claremont was that he was big on he
never shied away from killing people he
never shied away from from like the
x-men basically killing people they
wouldn't do it out of malice the action
wouldn't just be like you know what I'm
tired of you and then just killing you
didn't really see it all that often it
would be one of these things were like
it was just collateral damage but it but
it really went towards focusing on the
x-men themselves because then it's like
has a team that's basically a
peacekeeping group how do they handle
like by their own action getting someone
killed it went really really really well
in hand with everything that was going
on in terms of of focusing on like the
nature of the character development
there were in turn a couple of these
guys are rescued from this fire you end
up having magneto who steps in who
literally like dismantled their suits
and turns them into cocoons of sorts and
locks them in now right off the bat the
h-1 are just like bad guy and they
respond by intending to take out magneto
but man you don't respond by saying I'm
not here as an enemy I'm here as an ally
now this is important because again this
goes into the nature of Magneto becoming
somewhat of a good guy that's one of the
cool things about this is he's you know
the way he's drawn the way he speaks
he's a guy that comes to this with
experience he's made to be very very
human not some guy who's like I have
magnetism powers you know that's that's
not really how he was done back then
magneto is a guy who hates humans but in
this one in one of these instances it's
kind of like the enemy of my enemy is my
friend there is a group out there that
is hunting down mutants mercilessly
they're killing them everywhere they
find them and they're not taking
prisoners or you know no quarter is
being offered here and so it's really
kind of like a war on mutant kind
magneto becomes an ally of the x-men and
it is kind of cool the way this whole
thing plays out because then you end up
having a Kitty Pryde who kind of Stow's
away you know when when these they're
you know back at the Xavier Institute
when these purifiers come back to pick
up their camera a kitty probably sort of
Stow's away but the purifiers are ready
for them and that's one of the things to
bear in mind you know for her she's
inexperienced if this had been like
Colossus if it had been especially if
Cyclops were here it would have been a
more diplomatic approach I mean
diplomatic in so far probably more
stealthy approach is it better a better
word he used it would have been like we
can't go in guns blazing they have to be
prepared for us I mean if they were to
see if they were able to successfully
capture Xavier and Cyclops and storm
they had to have been prepared for us
and if they were prepared for us it
means they understand how our powers
work and they know how we function as a
team
Kitty Pryde is not that well versed she
just kind of shows up she tries to stow
away and you know immediately she's
captured by by the purifiers and so
while they're basically leaving with
Kitty Pryde you end up having the x-men
who were showing up with the other
purifiers now this is a really really
cool moment here because when it comes
to this kind of situation
Claremont again focused on the darker
side of the x-men the fact that they
were willing to do things that would
tote the line of what it meant to be a
good guy and sometimes just walk across
it entirely when you're Wolf rain and
you've been in the trenches and you've
done some pretty shady things you don't
really shy away from saying like hey
we're probably gonna have to kill some
folks we're gonna have to get our hands
dirty
he doesn't mind doing that it's the
nature of what he does and so we're
these purifiers kind of refused to talk
will they say like we're not worried
about this will rain kind of puffs his
claws but in the end of the day they
know it's taunting cuz all Wolverine can
really do is like kill them it's the
nature of what he does I mean you know
he's kind of pops his claws and he can
scratch them a little bit but with that
a mantium Wolverine doesn't really have
a whole lot of finesse it's just kind of
like I'm going to slash you and I'm
gonna kill you and that's really it
there's not a whole lot he can do here
he's not nuanced and so instead when
Wolverine kind of tries to torture them
and and LU they they hold their guns
Magneto's response is we have to go to
the darker side of things here we have
to do some bad things and so let me be
the bad guy who does bad things and so
what what magneto basically does here he
literally pulls apart the metal cocoons
that he wrapped these guys in and starts
put it like literally entering them into
their bodies it's like putting bamboo
reeds under their fingernails he's
torturing them he's torturing them for
information and and where the other
x-men look on and they're just kind of
like is this really something that we
should do well Ray's responses
absolutely this is absolutely what we
need to do these guys cannot be reasoned
with you cannot get them to talk fear
will not work the only thing that will
answer to is pain pain in the most
extreme form and it's literally just
shards of metal being twisted through
their physical bodies you know leaving
them in a state world oh they'll say
anything to make the pain stop
as one of these crazy things magneto is
well known to the purifiers he's
well-known as a guy who will do whatever
it takes in order to get the information
that he wants and in this instance
instead of like bombarding them with
psychic torture physical pain is what's
the worst because psychic torture is you
just kind of like screwing up the screw
of a person's mind and in a lot of ways
it can be worse but physical pain from
the master of magnetism sliding you know
shards of metal into your body like just
in and out of your body it's the most
extreme form of pain that they could
possibly imagine and so they'll tell the
truth because what this means is that if
they don't the pain will keep coming
they'll keep them here and then in turn
go and investigate their information and
if their information cut proves to be
false they'll come right back and the
pain will be worse the second time
around that it was the first because not
only do they want the information
they're also pissed off this guy lied so
again it's it's pretty dark and is
pretty twisted but it's the nature of
things okay
so picking up with really the conclusion
of God love God loves me and kills which
by the way I've got a cold you guys
could probably tell I'm actually getting
over it but still it sucks ooh baby way
picking up with God loves man kills the
the conclusion of all this we switch
over to Charles Xavier now this is where
you really start to see how screwed up
William Stryker is when this happens we
basically switch over to Manhattan to
the to the headquarters of the Stryker
Huseyin and one of the things that they
say you know the really kind of gets
thrown in here is and then they brought
they bring him under the place
Golgotha and they crucify him that is a
testament to Jesus Jesus was crucified
there now the idea behind this is that
when this happens with Xavier with him
being crucified it's all the x-men who
show up and literally start like
stabbing him deal jabbing at him ripping
his heart out as all these forms of
psychic torture now in reality this is
not truly happening but this is the
worst conceivable nightmare for Charles
Xavier and that's one of the things to
bear in mind is that for Charles Xavier
there's really kind of like two aspects
of what it is that he does you've got
the x-men so basically creating like a
peaceful coexistence between humans and
mutants and then you've got the x-men as
his actual children is really how he
sees them and the way that William
Stryker plays this out is that in the
midst of all this torture in this this
place of darkness and pain that he kind
of shows up is a savior of sorts it says
look to surrender yourself to me and
everything will be okay give yourself to
me and in turn I will lead you to
paradise very much presenting himself as
God or is it God as a christ-like figure
because it really fits well within the
religious themes of William Stryker and
the role that he plays the issue with
this is that Charles Xavier
resists to a degree now as one of these
things this has been going on for
fifteen hours and so there's no
there's really no end in sight and
that's the nature of William Stryker
when he goes in and he starts talking to
Philip Ramsey who's like a psychologist
who's the one implementing all the
psychological torture the results here
are that Xavier is slowly being broken
down now the other the other part of
this of course that you have Cyclops and
you have storm and the question is asked
to them is why are you doing this
like what's the basis behind all this in
the first place do you really just hate
mutants that much and the response of
William Stryker is is kind of amazing
here and this is where you start to see
you know Fox having drawn their elements
of his character but not really taking
the next step for fear of pissing off
all the Christians but the idea here is
that originally William Stryker was a
member of the US military and when he
had finally finished his you know his
leave where I guess his tour basically
or at least when he was on break from
his tour he and his wife were traveling
when of course she was pregnant and then
began to give birth to their child you
know in the midst of this car wreck that
they experienced when the when the
birthday process began and the child was
actually born William Stryker realized
it was a mutant and believing that it
was had killed the child now when his
wife asked for the baby he in turn broke
her neck this is a man that killed his
own wife and child is extreme now we're
this originally stemmed from fear he in
turn got into the vehicle and then lit a
match and him to kill both all of them
in the process and he was blown free
from the from the entire explosion and
in his mind he rationalized God saved me
from this fate God wants me to go
forward and destroy all these mutants
now the other part of this is this goes
into a guy by the name of Fred Duncan
now Fred Duncan was a character who's
created by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby and
he originally appeared would like to
banish her first showed up when it comes
to ball is one of these bear mom when it
comes to Marvel Comics you oftentimes
see liaisons right like when x-factor
first not really when they first showed
up when the the original x-men left
x-factor and a new team was brought in
in the early 1990s you got Valerie
Cooper and then you got Forge he
basically had these characters who were
like liaisons between x-factor and E and
the federal government with Fred Duncan
he was a liaison between the FBI and the
x-men themselves and so it was kind of
like a give-and-take here you'd be one
of those guys who basically warned the
x-men if something was coming down the
pipe that could threaten them where they
were they were gonna be needed but he
was also a character who the H would
relay information to on their various
goings on and things that were happening
now where this was kind of like a
tenuous relationship and where Fred
Duncan was more of a friend of of Xavier
and the rest of the x-men didn't truly
trust him when events began to unfold
like the like the the formation of
project wide-awake
when he started getting into the the
federal government basically using the
FBI the NSA the CIA all these various
organizations for the purpose of like
spying on the mutant threat
trying to contain and control at Fred
Duncan would pass information to the
x-men and basically become more of a
friend kind of giving them a step ahead
of what the federal government was doing
but the fact remains here this is one of
the things that William Stryker was
doing was that he had a member of the
Stryker who stayed working in the FBI
and that member was taking information
that was being gained by Fred Duncan and
pulling it in and giving it to William
Stryker the purifiers are all over the
place
anybody could be one of these guys it's
like a modern-day clan except they don't
wear white hoods and white outfits and
all that kind of crazy stuff look again
it's pretty extreme and it's pretty dark
now what we also have to remember here
is is that Kitty Pryde had basically
stowed away alongside with the purifiers
when they showed up at the Xavier
Institute while the rest of the x-men
were away and kidnap Illyana Rasputin
the sister of Colossus and so when this
happened of course Kitty Pryde location
was it like the purifiers were aware
that she was there they essentially used
nerve gas to knock her out but when they
actually get to the location when the
question is asked you know it's a
William Stryker
we have Illyana Rasputin what he wanted
to do with Kitty Pryde he said we says
killer the guys willing to kill a
fifteen-year-old girl it's existing it's
extreme now of course Kitty Pryde makes
her escape but the problem with this is
that she still suffering from the
effects of nerve gas which hasn't
totally worn off yet and so her phasing
powers aren't at 100% she's literally
just kind of fleeing for her life and so
in this instance when Kitty Pryde
basically makes her way into the Bronx
she ends up running across a gang and of
course we know what the gangs integers
are weather despite the fact that she's
15 years old and so were they trying to
make a move and I basically try to force
themselves on earth of course you have
an for the purifiers who shows up who in
turn looks to kill Kitty Pryde now this
is the nature of the purifiers they'll
kill whoever gets in their way
it doesn't matter who you are if you are
in the way of them and a mutant they
will kill you to get to that mute is how
extreme they are and so of course an
intern kills all the gang members Kitty
Pryde manages to make her escape and
then of course calls Nightcrawler back
at the Xavier Institute and says hey
here's where I am and then of course
there's a massive explosion the
purifiers are still chasing her down
that's the intensity that goes on here
yes the purifiers are human yes they
tire but KT prize in a weakened state
they will constantly
chase her until they finally get a hold
of her it's the nature of who they are
and so in this moment you know when she
finally manages the stowaway aboard a
subway train and manages to make her
escape but the purifiers track her down
they chase her down they try to take her
out and of course that leads to the
arrival of Colossus will reign
Nightcrawler all nine yards and they
basically take out these purifiers and
of course is a survivor she manages to
make her escape but it's still pretty
extreme because then you switch back
over to Charles Xavier and this is where
the the continued mental torture of
Charles Xavier
has begun to finally take its
that the the psychic torture he's been
experiencing has slowly been eroding
away at his mental blocks to the point
that when William Stryker finally steps
in and says are you ready to embrace the
Word of God are you ready to become a
believer in the power of Christ that
that in turn xavier responses yes
and the william stryker says then kill
cyclops and spork and where he initially
resists what wave shocker does here is
he says only those who are worthy will
be accepted only those who are worthy
will be viewed by me
as being worthy so if you truly want to
to attain the splendor of heaven if you
truly want to attain something greater
then you have to kill them and Charles
Xavier says okay and he kills Cyclops
and storm and it is mind-blowing when
this happened like I remember reading
this actually the animated series my dad
introduced me to comic books and I in
turn start reading everything I possibly
can't what I'm reading this all blew me
away and it's like okay Xavier is ready
because what they're gonna do is they're
gonna go to this garden this massive
event that they're putting on like a
giant Church sermon and what's gonna go
on behind the scenes is Xavier mind is
gonna pick up everyone who's a mutant
and all those mutants who were there are
gonna be killed by Xavier and so what
you end up having like Philip Ramsey who
basically gets in his vehicle and leaves
to go back and change get a shower so on
and so forth and then head to the garden
proper he's intercepted by Kurt Wagner
now this is where Nightcrawler begins to
show his darker half where he really is
more of like a loving and a gentle
character when it comes down to it my
collar can scare the hell out of you
because of how he looked I mean if you
got someone that shows up to you looking
like a devil and then starts teleporting
you around the world it's gonna scare
you out of your wits and that's
literally what he does with Philip he
snatches him up and says like I'm here
to inflict pain and torture I'm here to
take all the nightmares you've ever had
of what might know of what mutants are
and I'm here to bring them to your
doorstep we have a lot of ways that we
can make you hurt we have even more ways
that we can kill you so which one is it
gonna be do you want to hurt or do you
want to die and so ultimately Philip
Ramsey hands the information over it's
where you end up having you know the
bodies of storm in Cyclops who were
unceremoniously thrown on these beds and
then carted down to the incinerators you
end up having like the elevator was just
like jerks up to the top because they
have Illyana Rasputin going with them
you know it's like it literally jerks to
the top and just plunges out of the
building only for us to find out magneto
was the one who's doing it and so and
the purifier jumps out of the elevator
grabs onto the edge of the building
flees for her life and then you have
like Wolverine assists Anna says they're
not dead now to be honest and this is a
bit of a MacGuffin but that's the nature
of Chris Claremont storytelling right
like Chris Claremont doesn't tell this
for shock value with Chris Claremont
when he wrote these
stories the way that he when he did
things like this it was designed for the
purpose to show how bad things were it's
designed to show you how broken Charles
Xavier is well then the question becomes
if they're not dead why are they not
dead and the answer to this question is
because Charles Xavier is still fighting
back there's still some part of him
that's fighting back as best he can and
so what are you decisional II done will
shut down the minds of storm and Cyclops
as far as anybody out there using
machines to read them was aware they
were dead because their mental patterns
were operating at such a low rate that
they would seem to be dead it's a cool
little thing to see because it shows the
bond between Xavier and the x-men that
is this unbreakable thing that Xavier
while he died has done some shady things
well he has dozens of things that maybe
seem like betrayal the one thing he
would not do is kill his own x-men
stories like these are why events like
Avengers vs. x-men when Cyclops kills
Xavier is so significant but with Xavier
being in the mental state that William
Stryker expect him to be in that's one
of the important things to bear in mind
Xavier is fighting in such a way to
where subconsciously he'll preserve the
x-men who are you're talking about the
rest of the mutant population and Xavier
does not care for the rest of the medon
population the way he does care for the
x-men and so this is still a tangible
possibility that Xavier will be brought
to the garden that he'll he'll be put on
display for the world to see that
William Stryker will use him to kill all
the mutants in this immediate vicinity
turn him into a weapon and then
internally it's really just kind of a
testbed will this work in this immediate
area and if it will well then in turn
like I can espouses and say see guys
God hates mutants look at this because
no one's gonna know that Xavier is the
one that's doing it there's gonna be
like hey guys God hates mutants like
look at look at God's smiting the mutant
population so again it's extreme
remember that's the nature of William
Stryker well all that's happening the
power of Xavier is being put to work and
all these various mutants are being made
to suffer Thermage being scrambled or
they're really on the verge of being
killed you have magneto who fights back
as best he can't but there's only so
much that he can do one of the things to
bear in mind here though is the nature
of the people who were attending when it
comes to something like this when it
comes to extreme views extreme views
draw extremists and extreme views make
extremists out of non extreme people as
though it's literally fear-mongering is
telling people exactly what they want to
hear that's exactly what William Stryker
does here and it works
stupendously because in a state of
desperation people will believe what
they want to believe and so you've
already got people who already have this
sort of basis you know baseline hatred
for the mutant population William
Stryker comes along and says behold a
power of Christ amplifies that mutant
hatred and then in turn uses
fear to amplify their fear and hate even
more it's one of the best political
maneuvers a person can make so that's
one the reasons why chris claremont
storytelling was incredibly political it
was always political it was never not
political but it was always cool the way
that it was done as where you have the
x-men basically trying to fight off as
best they can the only people who are
being affected here are mutants and so
what this means is that with Charles
Xavier is mind working it's kind of like
a beacon it's kind of a radar it kind of
reveals the the hidden mutant population
among them one of whom is an who's
actually one of the members of the
purifiers what admitting power is we
don't know we're never told but William
Stryker doesn't care and so we're an has
been faithful his best soldier to this
point he pushes her off the platform she
falls it breaks her neck and that's the
end of ant this unceremonious into an
otherwise devoted follower who turned
out to be a mutant that's just the way
this game gets played and so as a result
the devices that are being used to kind
of amplify the power of Xavier are taken
out by Cyclops and in doing so that
leads to the rest of the x-men kind of
asking the question what do we do now
and the initial response is a we can
kill William Stryker but the response of
Cyclops is no we're not going to kill
him what we're going to do is we're
going to discredit him and that's the
best move that he can make and the
reason why is because you're talking
about this massive gathering is being
televised all across the world
if the x-men walked in there and killed
him it wouldn't make him a martyr and so
Cyclops walks in and says we have to
debate him we have to destroy his
credibility on TV and reduce his
argument down to nothing that's the best
way to win because winning the hearts
and minds of people is not done through
physical violence and so when you have
the Cyclops who goes in and says hey
look we're gonna have a debate we're
gonna argue with you his response is
like yes we're mutants but like we're
also human beings too we have abilities
but our our abilities so different from
like a world-class astronomer or a
master chess player are they really that
different these gifts sure manifests in
a physical way and some of them are
dangerous but just like any other
circumstance a villain like a criminal
with a handgun a gangbanger a doctor the
practices euthanasia whatever the case
is we have an ability we have a gift and
we can use it for good or evil there are
those of us who use it for evil and
those of us who use it for good but does
that mean that every gun owner is a bad
guy does it mean that every gun owner is
a criminal of course it doesn't it means
that there are those who own guns and
there are those who are going to commit
bad acts with them but just because a
person can do a bad thing doesn't mean
they will do a bad thing we are not an
inherently evil group of people but
that's the nature of extremist views
extremist views do not see grey areas
it's a very very dangerous ideology to
have and because he's quartered in this
because of the fact that he's that he's
told by my Cyclops look for all you know
it could be that we're baseline humans
and that you're the mutation that
everybody that that people are supposed
to be born with powers because I mean
Cyclops is really kind of talked about
as vast that point but it's like people
are born with powers you are born
without powers so what if you're the
mutation here and even if that's not the
case we are the next step in human
evolution men were Apes once and that
literally is an affront to everything
William Stryker beliefs divine creation
God created heaven the earth firmament
you know all that kind of good stuff and
in his desperation he does the only
thing he knows how to do
he turns to violence and he literally
pulls a gun and pointed a kitty frog
with the intention of shooting her and
the x-men stand down they stand there
and do nothing because what this does is
it shows that the argument of William
Stryker has no merit there's no real
ground to her distantly him just
espousing nonsense under the belief that
like people will believe him and when
there's nothing left when when the
foundation of his argument is literally
destroyed he turns to violence
violence is an act of desperation and
it's an act of desperation by desperate
men and women when they have nothing
else they'll turn to violence the x-men
stand down and they shot by a cop and
one of the cops is just like he was
gonna shoot a fifteen-year-old
unarmed trial not a chance I was gonna
let that happen this cop does his duty
he shoots William Stryker as the Axman
have done nothing wrong here the x-men
are our victims of an otherwise deranged
man who believes big God wants him to
kill mutants this guy was gonna kill
innocent people I shot this guy he's
gonna go to jail
the x-men you're free to go your victims
of a kidnapping and torture just just
get out of here and so following that
what this does is this leads to this
really really interesting scenario we
kind of go into this epilogue and you
basically have like the aftermath of all
this and William Stryker is taken to
jail and so on and so forth and the
x-men are talking to Charles Xavier and
Charles Xavier
starts to adopt the mindset of Magneto
and this comes out of transitive music
Charles Xavier experience the guy was
tortured
consistently for almost a full 24 hours
he was psychologically tortured and it
almost destroyed his perception of
humanity what happens when you encounter
a man who is so fanatical who is so far
gone that his belief system is derived
from faith derived from God his
incorruptible unshakable thing and he
says because of my faith because of this
unshakable belief I am going to wipe out
the entirety of the mutant population
what do you do in the face of that how
do you function in the face of that what
William Stryker showed Charles Xavier is
that there are men out there whose
hearts and minds cannot be changed they
cannot be reasoned with
they can't be bargained with there's
nothing you can do to convince them that
way is the wrong way that the only way
to really stop him is to kill them and
what that's done is this destroyed
Charles Xavier is perception that a
peaceful coexistence can be achieved
that he sits on this chair and says
maybe Magneto's right maybe there really
is no way to save the hearts and minds
of man because William Stryker wasn't
religious Fundamentalist
but what happens when you have men and
women in positions of power that cannot
be touched they cannot be stopped akin
and sometimes can't even be seen because
their presences are so secretive what
happens when they're the ones whose
hearts and minds can't be changed what
happens when a person decides they want
to press the nuclear option what happens
will you run into that situation how do
you cope with that how do you deal with
that and Xavier Swan says you can't
William Stryker showed me that there
were people out there who just can't be
they can't be convinced and if they
can't be convinced then maybe this is
this is a fruitless effort maybe it's
pointless but the argument Cyclops makes
here is no it's not we instructor was
one man what do you have to say about
the cop who shot him what do you have to
say about those who began to look at
what wing Strucker was saying and say
maybe this really is too extreme maybe
this really is too hardcore I'm all
against stopping those who were
dangerous but like I'm not in favor of
killing mutant children who haven't done
anything wrong and like how what do you
say to those guys what'd you say to them
are you gonna look that cop in the eye
and you're gonna say thanks for saving
my life but like you're still a credible
threat though like are you really gonna
say that William Stryker was an
extremist example but for every extreme
William Stryker out there there's a cop
there's that one cop with red hair who
saved his life and so because that like
you you can't take it as extremes it's
really Cyclops making the argument of
saying this is how you become a William
Stryker sure you're not a religious
fundamentalist who believes that God
wants you to kill mutants but you are
becoming like Magneto and Magneto really
is at the end of the day nothing more
than another William Stryker but on the
opposite end of the spectrum and that's
kind of a mind-blowing perception to
throw out there to see magneto put in
that light but it kind of make the
argument that he really kind of is the
same way and so with his face kind of
the Fate kind of being shaken xavier
goes forwards really kind of having to
ask himself some very serious questions
is it worth it to continue this peaceful
coexistence you know is it the Cyclops
is better suited to leave the x-men than
he is there's these different things
that go in there these have been
arguments that are made and what this
does is it kind of feeds into the future
of the x-men stories under Chris
Claremont going forward for the next
seven years until Claremont leaves and
helps to kind of build things even
further but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come it's
explained make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the rock or if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later
purse
you